[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day why don't
we talk about three topics today that
someone took on their TV of Shannon
Sharpe on fs1 uploaded that to the
internet and now it's become this
beautiful mean it's on Twitter usually
the meme takes the format of you saying
something like Pam I'm engaged Jim :
play that video that ain't no problem
that's an office reference I feel like
you're Shannon Sharpe fan Chris what's
going on here what do you think so
especially with me so happy right now
words my voice just so that's not
Shannon Sharpe normal voice it went into
a higher register and then everyone
loved that and has probably like we got
a call but you know you don't call for
then you get it's like your voice goes
around the carpet your voice
going into a higher register that ain't
no problem answers its own question it's
like an alright I want to move on to the
next story this one comes to us from New
Hampshire where a man stripped naked in
a Planet Fitness he was being arrested
he said I thought this was a
judgment-free zone which of course is
the slogan of Planet Fitness Natasha I
feel like you got a kick out of this I
think this moment will be studied an ad
agency
you know like he did say the slogan yes
so we have to be very clear about what
we need when we pick it you know like
what is it Nike just do it I mean that
could be further
Trump just changes the whole like
government to be like we're running on
Dunkin you got in trouble not for just
like exercising there he was doing yoga
which is the funniest way it's the
funniest thing to do naked for sure
cuz there's all the positions Tripos the
warrior lots of things are pointing
downward I mean it's downward dog do you
guys get naked at the gym at all even in
the locker room you're a known icky man
I'm a known a key why I call it a
pee-pee the gym gets naked anyway I've
heard so many blowies in this button
like this team what you've heard I was
like is that a blowy going on and then
as if to say yes the I heard like to my
gym yeah Jordan and I do go to the same
gym I feel like it's only a matter of
time until we see I don't want to bring
it up I did see you walk around with a
towel just Jess over here there's a
whole towel you could have wrapped it
around
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and may wonders why people don't make
eye contact with him in the hallway why
don't you talk to me at work well I love
this and also it's so funny that you're
like look look I'm sorry you saw my
naked pie did you know he saw you know I
also when I'm at the gym I'd take my
glasses off and I don't work so it's
just kind of a blurry fun time of
exercise I'm naked the towels here and
which like when you're you take your
contacts off or your take when I take my
glasses off and I can't see anything
I automatically assume no one else can
right yes same with when I put in my
headphones and I'm like I'm gonna let
this fart go exactly no one's gonna hear
it Wow
well we we talked about the Mickey at
the gym a little longer than I thought
we would but I've got one last story I
want to squeeze into our internet
roundup today and that's for tonight
it's fortnight's birthday happy birthday
fortnight birthday very fun video game
specifically we're talking about the
Battle Royale version which you can play
for free on ps4 Xbox consoles mobile
games it's one of the most fun games
I've ever played I wish I was better at
it Jordan you've considered playing but
haven't quite pulled the trigger yet why
are you scared to play I don't know I
just am afraid of getting noobs like
people saying a new new new and is like
doing a little dance once you kill
someone and then you can I don't want to
play it but now that I've heard today's
challenge is to dance in front of
birthday cakes I'm like I'll just play
that portion is a member SimCity but you
on the ground and you and a Bailey ran
that's what happens Oh SimCity if you
got a bad neighborhood people start
rioting in a revolt and you're just the
people right and revote in a bad city
that's what this becomes that that's
what I think I feel like this morning
when we were talking about it I feel
like you are also drawn to the fort part
of this enjoy a nice fort every night
you made some parts as a knight though
to things I like so many parts you like
that I build a pillow fort onto the set
what night just night day here look fort
it's like a board game day but like with
forts yeah yeah let us know if you think
we should do that and hey speaking of
the YouTube comments section of Ryan I
want to throw to you now what's what's
going on in the YouTube community
section today thanks Nate let me tell
you community section today I'm going to
be putting up my favorite reno911.com
this week's 15 year anniversary since
the premiere of the show
and my favorite clip is the one where
it's about the lottery where they come
in and they all think that they've got
the lottery and it's just total chaos
after their so check it out in the
YouTube community section and to honor
that clip and the anniversary I have got
scratch-off tickets um for you guys oh
come on and just to let you know if you
win I get part of it
death death the rules let's go ahead and
check out the clip in the YouTube
community section and let me know what
your favorite clip is from Reno 911 and
we'll talk about it online
thanks Ryan we're gonna do something
different right now hey hey welcome to a
new segment where I assess the morality
of the internet this is tell me that
isn't porn is that a
recently I discovered something on the
internet that I am shocked shocked to
learn is not considered pornography and
I am of course talking about ASMR videos
ASMR means autonomous sensory meridian
response and apparently for some people
these videos elicit like a little tingly
sensation down their spine but as far as
I can tell that's not all that's
tingling if you don't know what ASMR
videos are lucky you because these are
videos where busty chicks talk really
quietly make weird little noises and do
bizarre stuff with objects which sounds
a lot like pornography to me so let's go
to the videotape what is happening here
makeup brush on the microphone I don't
think it's porn but I do think it's
making me uncomfortable the way porn -
Jordan yes hi tell me that is important
it's not porn it's just fun it makes me
feel good it works you the tango yes I
get the tingle no one else got sting no
and little like spit bubbles and all
that she's really good she's good I
really like this send me the week later
sure I will next video ah Nate tell me
this isn't porn ok costume some porn has
costumes babe I don't think that's a
costume watch this watch this
uh-huh oh ok 4 towel roll that's kind of
phallic and listen hear what's happening
I mean I guess I could see like like
symbolically that's supposed to
represent the male phallus and you know
she's make she she has made your male
phallus happy by drawing the smiley face
on it which is what porn supposed to do
anything tell me that's not porn
I think it's porn in the sense that any
you could masturbate to anything thereby
making it pornographic but I I don't
think this is in point Brian I don't
think it's intended to be porn I'm gonna
say now what is the definition of
pornographic I think nature summed it up
anything you can masturbate that's
true that's kind of a sec I've seen porn
before and that's it right there
tell me that's not porn does this give
you a tingle Jordan it allowed cure Oh
tell me that's not pornography did you
like that no I didn't like that one
actually that one didn't work that
didn't work didn't know tingle because
that also represents the phallus and
she's just chomping she's challenged
everything's a phallus
everything's pornography next video tell
me that's not porn Hannah she's naked
there are boobs in it boobs oh yeah no
one kisses important
that's not poor not the porn i watch boy
we seem to feel pretty confident that
this stuff isn't porn then I ask you
folks I ask you what about this one I've
ever seen on the Internet
tell me that's not porn this is too
uncomfortable we need to stop feel
something that's John Goodman yeah well
I don't know I guess good luck to him
whoever it is keep at it you know stick
with your YouTube channel will will
subscribe folks that was truly
unsettling and there you have it
ASMR is truly NSFW
rules on scratch-off win prize in prize
box this is really fun Ryan thanks it's
fun everyone gambling thing I got a
seven I got a seven that's me and a
rower in a diagonal come on eighty I
didn't want to see my prize damn it well
it would have been class I'm sorry Ryan
I don't think Oh fine thanks for the
losing lottery ticket Ryan that's so
messed up well we're all losers but go
go check out that clip in the YouTube
community section and I just want to
know what I would have won
[Music]
you